when you got drafted to the saints
what that that season who was the
quarterback is jake deloam and
well yeah wow jake dillon came on was
that where he like
he was like he was a third string guy
yeah and he just kicked before we we
knew him with the panthers
he went to the super bowl exactly he
can't he came in against the cowboys and
beat a playoff ball and cowboys team and
that was really kind of his coming out
party that year
who were you hoping to get drafted to
the browns the browns this is
this is like the that was was that the
first year the browns were back that's
for sure they were back and they would
they take tim couch i took tim couch
how'd that [ __ ] happen so exactly so
the first thing is
is i wanted to be the first player
because i thought i deserved it
two you were the best player in the
draft and two
yeah yeah and two i felt like just who i
was and the way i played the game it
just fit well
cleveland cleveland like it's a grimy
town like they would appreciate
exactly like jim brown was there exactly
exactly
that that was what i was hoping for it
didn't work out and then my next
my next was uh indy because i thought it
would have been cool to play with uh
with payton
yeah no no my next was fit was uh was
philly and because i was the quarterback
of philly
it wasn't mcnabb was it that's who they
drafted oh so it was that year
so they drafted mcnabb's it was he was
number two that year
so that was my second choice because
andy reid
i just love the west coast offense uh i
think i'm the type
and it seems like you were right he's
been onto something yeah exactly
exactly i love that offense and then
third was um
indy played with peyton and i i got
skipped past all those and ended up in
new orleans